all right welcome back so today we're
starting a lecture series on the Fourier
transform in particular the discrete or
fast Fourier transform okay so let's get
started
Fourier transform okay
I don't assume that you have any
background in Fourier analysis or even
really in linear algebra or differential
equations this certainly would help to
study Fourier analysis but really all
that we need is calculus okay
so we're only going to introduce this
assuming that you know calculus and
we're going to kind of derive the
important and interesting features of
the Fourier transform okay good and in
particular we're really going to be
talking about the discrete Fourier
transform okay so the the kind of
regular Fourier transform you're used to
hearing about is defined on kind of
continuous functions but here we're
going to be talking about data okay okay
good
so we're pretty familiar with Taylor
series at this point I hope we're going
to use Taylor series a lot in the
section on numerical differentiation and
integration and also of integration of
particles through vector fields so I
think it's good for us to kind of
refresh ourselves okay so I just want to
start by saying some functions are
really well approximated by Taylor
series
okay
if you don't remember what the Taylor
series is please please remind yourself
do some examples it's very very
important so maybe I'll just do kind of
one quick example just on the side right
so if I have some if I have some
function f let's say that I know my
function f about some nominal value and
I also know all of its derivatives so I
know F at X naught and let's just call
this F at some point X and all of its
derivatives so its derivatives being DF
DX evaluated at x d squared f DX squared
evaluated at x and so on okay then what
we can do is we can approximate F
evaluated at nearby points to X so even
if we only know this information right
like my boss emails me F evaluated at X
and the derivatives I don't know what F
is I don't know anything about it except
these quantities then what the Taylor
series allows me to do or Taylor
expansion it allows me to approximate
nearby values in terms of these
quantities so if I have f of X plus
Delta X right so I'm using Delta to mean
that it's close by then this is going to
equal f of X plus Delta x times DF DX
evaluated at the point X I know this
plus Delta x squared over two factorial
times the second derivative of F
with respect to X evaluated at X I'm
just gonna write the third element
because maybe it'll help to understand
Delta X cubed over 3 factorial d squared
F sorry D cubed F DX cubed evaluated at
X plus dot dot dot higher order terms
okay so this is now written in terms of
quantities I know I know F DF D squared
D cubed F all evaluated at the point X
and this gives me an approximation to F
at a nearby point X plus Delta X ok so
please refresh yourself on this Taylor
expansion that's very very very
important for almost everything we're
doing from here on in try it out on some
examples right see if so assume x equals
0 that's the base point that we're
expanding about and f of x equals sine x
right try to compute the Taylor
expansion for sine X about the point 0
okay
so that was just an aside the point I
really wanted to make is that some
functions ok so some functions are well
approximated by Taylor series right
that's what we just wrote here and I'm
gonna give you an example so if my
function f of X equals say X to the
fourth minus x squared excuse me this
looks like this kind of to Hill thing
here so here's X here's F let's say that
this point is 0 so it's kind of
symmetric about 0 then what the Taylor
series does and in the section on
numerical differentiation you can find I
think there will be some codes that
essentially in the straight what the
different Taylor expansion
you look like so if you really are not
feeling comfortable with Taylor
expansions you can kind of look for that
that material okay so at if we expand
this about x equals zero then our first
order Taylor expansion it just looks
like a line with slope zero right that's
just the term we saw DF DX evaluated at
zero it's just a line with slope zero
this is the kind of P equals 1 the first
order polynomial going back here to the
left board I call these polynomials
because I get a polynomial in Delta X
okay so you know if this was f at Delta
X and X was 0 this would just be F of 0
plus Delta X DF DX 0 plus Delta x
squared over 2 factorial d squared F DX
squared at 0 so on and so forth and you
can think of this as a polynomial
expansion in powers of Delta X ok so our
first poll our first order polynomial
expansion right power 1 is just this
zero slope line our second-order
polynomial expansion is going to be this
parabola looking thing right this is P
equals 2 my third order it's a little
harder for me to draw but it's probably
something like something like this P
equals 3 but by the time we get our
fourth order Taylor series approximation
we actually exactly represent our
function because it in fact is exactly
represented by a polynomial okay so some
functions are well approximated by tail
series and some are not okay
so I would say this as some functions
are ill-suited for Taylor expansion
ill-suited or just bad for Taylor
expansion
okay so can you think to yourself what
would be an example of a bad function
for Taylor expanding one where it's
really gonna be hard to approximate it
with a polynomial think back to your
calculus class what are some functions
we've seen that are not well
approximated by polynomials
well one really good example is a sine
wave okay so a sine wave needs an
infinite polynomial expansion to be
represented accurately so let's try f of
X equals sine X okay here I'm going to
have something similar maybe this is
zero okay that's a sine wave X F sine of
X okay so my first my first order
polynomial is going to be a straight
line with slope one and you can kind of
do this on paper and pencil on your own
and verify kind of what is the first
order Taylor expansion the second order
third order like write down the Taylor
series for sine of X and just look at
the first term then both the first and
second term first second and third terms
and so on so this is the linear
approximation for a first order Taylor
series a second order one I'm not going
to try to draw it but the third order
just looks like a cubic function right
in cubic functions have two switching
points this is P equals three a fifth
order polynomial is going to have four
switching points P equals five but every
time I want to come I want to capture
one more period of my sine wave I need
to bump my polynomial order up another
factor of two so if I wanted to add
another another period then I would have
to or another half period on each side
then I would have to have a seventh
order polynomial okay so this is just
gets worse and worse and worse the
farther away from my origin I look the
higher order polynomial I need to
represent it accurately okay so this is
a problem with Taylor series that
they're not good for all functions okay
okay
so the key point now is instead of
expanding a function in terms of
polynomials
okay in terms of polynomials which is
what we do in the case of Taylor
expansion its instead possible to
represent our function as a sum of sine
waves
okay so we're representing our function
as a sum of sine waves okay
this is the basic idea of a Fourier
series okay this is Fourier series as
opposed to a Taylor series good okay and
for example in the case we were just
looking at over here where we have this
sine wave we need exactly one sine wave
of one frequency to represent this so
this is in some sense perfect for a
Fourier series so we only need a single
sine wave for example - and in some
sense this is an example that we cooked
up to be particularly easy to represent
with Fourier series but it is still true
that there's a whole category of
functions that are good for Taylor
series and in an entirely different
category of functions which are good for
Fourier series okay good
great so now we're going to talk about
this theory of expanding functions in
terms of sine x some frequency
and in fact we're going to be talking
about doing this purely on data okay so
this is not a course on Fourier analysis
and so I'm not going to go through weeks
and weeks about converging integrals and
orthonormal polynomial or function space
bases it's extremely interesting stuff
really some very fascinating and
beautiful mathematics goes into
understanding the Fourier transforms for
example we're used to thinking of kind
of vector spaces as being directions XY
and Z for example but the theory that
goes into Fourier analysis tells you
that you can also have kind of function
spaces that are spanned by polynomials
1x x squared X cubed right and that's
the Taylor series basis and I can also
span functions by signs of higher and
higher frequencies sine Omega T sine 2
Omega T sine 3 Omega T and so on and so
forth but that's a little bit well we're
getting a little ahead of ourselves okay
okay so this is an entire there is an
entire theory of expanding functions in
terms of sines
and I'm going to say sine of K Omega X
and this is called Fourier analysis
okay that's all I'm gonna say about
Fourier analysis now we are interested
in handling data
okay so MATLAB one of the reasons MATLAB
is so great is because it takes this
world view that data is all that matters
I don't care if my function is smooth or
if I even can write down what the
function is let's say I have an
experiment and it gives me data and I
have data at particular points in time
or space how do I do the Fourier
transform on data okay so we are
interested in data and the great thing
about data is that it actually requires
significantly less kind of hardcore
mathematical theory ok so there's some
beautiful theory underlying this but
doing Fourier transforms on data is not
so complicated so we're interested in
extracting frequencies from data
okay now I'm gonna give you an example
of what this data looks like and then
I'm going to tell you what the Fourier
transform is okay so I'm just going to
draw a picture of my data okay here we
have some function defined on some
variable X and I'm just going to draw
some function some function okay but I
don't have I can't write down this
function I can't say it's three e to the
sine Omega T it's it's just data at this
point right I have a bunch of data to
find it points X 0 X 1 dot dot dot all
the way up to X big n minus 1 okay so if
you count this this is a total of big n
data points I'm going to call this F 0 F
1 all the way up to f n minus 1 where f
n minus 1 is equal to f of X and minus 1
we kind of assume that there is a
function underlying that's a smooth well
behaved function but all I know are
these data points okay and we might
assume that these are separated by a
delta X some kind of fixed increment
where I'm sampling that's a pretty good
assumption okay
so the whole goal here is to take a set
of numbers right my n F of 0 F 1 F 2
dots is to take my set of numbers F 0 F
1 dot dot dots F n minus 1 right it's
just a bunch of numbers that I've
collected from in experiments and I want
to go through some procedure and I want
to pull out some kind of frequency
components I want to know is this thing
really high frequency is there some low
frequency pattern I want to know what
are the frequency components I'm going
to call those F 0 hat F 1 hat all the
way up to F n minus 1 hat and the thing
that takes me from my data to my
frequencies is called the discrete
Fourier transform the D F T so this is D
F T ok this is the picture that we're
working with today we have data and we
want to pull out the frequency content I
haven't told you exactly what these mean
yet but we want to pull out the
frequency content and we're going to do
it by using the discrete Fourier
transform good ok so let's just think
about that for a minute
and again before I kind of tell you
exactly what those frequencies mean I'm
going to write up the formula that we
use to obtain them okay all right so on
a new board we're going to say what we
really want is okay we have our data F 0
F 1 dot dot dot F n minus 1 I'm just
rewriting what we had on the other board
so we have it fresh in our mind and
we're gonna get F 0 hats F 1 hat dot dot
dot F M minus 1 hat okay so this is my
data and these are my Fourier
coefficients so the discrete Fourier
transform takes me from data to Fourier
coefficients DFT and it's just a formula
this is the discrete version of the
continuous Fourier transform for those
of you who are familiar with this we
have F K hat is equal to the sum from
little N equals zero to big n minus 1 of
my nth data point F sub n times e to the
minus 2 pi I K little n / begin ok now
this is this takes a little bit of
parsing so I'm going to tell you kind of
what all of this means but this is the
discrete Fourier transform
okay the DFT so I have data and it gives
me some kind of frequency coefficients
okay I'll tell you what these mean but
this is the formula to get them so it
only depends on data and this quantity
which I can compute right K I know K
little n varies from zero to big n minus
one and big n is the number of samples
I've collected so let's get our heads
around what this e to the 2 pi stuff
really means ok so there's a formula
called I think it's called Euler's
formula maybe I'll do this in a
different color so recall that e to the
I theta right I as a complex number the
square root of negative 1 e to the
square root of negative 1 times theta is
equal to cosine of theta plus I times
sine of theta this is a very very useful
formula called Euler's formula okay and
the way I think about these complex
numbers is the following so e to the I
theta is a coordinate in the complex
plane on the complex unit circle so you
can verify to yourself that if I take
the magnitude of the real part squared
plus the magnitude of the imaginary part
squared that's Coast squared plus sine
squared that always equals 1 so all of
these points have unit length 1 in the
complex plane and the angle is given by
theta right this is Theta so my real
part is cos theta and my imaginary part
is sine theta ok so that's exactly what
this formula is saying
these define a complex number with
coordinates cos theta in the real
direction sine theta in the imaginary
direction and so if I look at this
quantity 2 pi I times this number 2 pi
is a full revolution of the circle
ok so 2 pi I times let's say K and over
big n this number K n over big n tells
me what fraction of the circle I've gone
around ok that's what this geometrically
means these are complex numbers and E -
a complex number is a position on the
unit circle ok but you see that these
now are frequencies right e to the 2 pi
I times this is really cosine of 2 pi
times that frequency plus I sine of that
frequency so what I like to say is that
2 pi K and over big n is a frequency
okay it's some frequency that my signal
is oscillating at and these are the
coefficients for that frequency so I'm
taking my my original data
I'm taking my original data and I'm
breaking it up into a sum of sine waves
of different frequencies and these f
hats are the magnitudes of each of those
sine waves so it's f naught hat times
sine of my first frequency plus F 1 hat
times sine of my second frequency and so
on and so forth ok good so I think I'll
just give you kind of a sketch of how I
see this even though it's maybe not the
most 100% accurate thing so take this
with a grain of salt sorry first I
should just write up what is the inverse
Fourier transform
so this is what I use f hats are
constructed okay so we go from data to
frequency content and then we can go
from we can use the F hats to construct
F by the inverse DFT so I DFT this is
not a product that Apple has come out
with this is not the Apple trademarked
DFT this is just the inverse DFT and
that tells me that once I have these
frequency components if that's what my
boss sends me in an email is a bunch of
frequencies and I need to reconstruct
the data I say okay well F n little n is
one over big n one over my number of
samples times the sum from k equals 0 to
n minus 1 of FK hat e to the positive 2
pi I K and over big n ok so this is the
discrete Fourier transform and this is
the inverse discrete Fourier transform
ok so it's not so bad I mean there's a
lot of theory that goes underneath why
these are important quantities to look
at but it's really nothing terribly
profound at this point it's just a nice
formula that's pretty easy to compute so
the picture I like to think of and this
again is not the complete story but this
is a nice cartoon for your to think
about is that I have some function f on
a domain X this is going to be the exact
same function we drew on the right side
of the board basically right we have
some function and let's see how many
data points do I want to have here kind
of want 4 here so 1 2 3 4
okay I'm going to say that this occupy
is a length of L in physical space this
is kind of from zero to Big L this is my
length I'm just trying to give this some
physical units because really this is a
fantastic engineering tool and I don't
want it to look like it's all math okay
so what we're saying is that I can write
this function as the sum of a bunch of
higher frequency sine waves okay so f is
equal to some zero frequency sine wave
like whatever the distance whatever the
the kind of mean of this quantity is is
just some zero frequency sine wave so
this is mean K equals zero so here this
is the K equals zero coefficients okay
so that's f naught hat times this plus F
1 hat times some big sine wave all right
some some sign a period to sorry I have
period pi L so this is K equals 1 you
know sine PI L X rather pi x over L so I
add the second coefficient times this
thing this is the second coefficient
when K is 1 plus f2 hat times the next
higher frequency sine wave which looks
like this all right this is K equals 2
and so on and so forth and I can add up
higher and higher and higher frequency
sines and then I exactly reconstruct
this data and so what this is telling me
is how my data is broken up into how big
is the mean
versus all of these different frequency
contributions okay and one of the main
applications of this is in audio all
right so let's say I have a microphone
and I'm sampling some audio signal I
might want to know if it's in a C sharp
or D flat you know and that would be
that would I would know what the note is
by what is the magnitude of each
frequency component a really cool
example I think someone should build an
iPhone app for this but to my knowledge
no one has I don't see why you couldn't
diagnose the engine problems in a car by
taking your cell phone plopping it on
the hood of your running car and have it
listen to the sound that your car's
making and based on the different
frequency weights the kind of energy in
each of these frequency bands you could
tell if your Ford truck from you know
2002 is running how it's supposed to or
if there's some problem just kind of a
cool idea just throw out there okay good
so we told you what the discrete Fourier
transform is I told you how we get it
from the data and I draw in a kind of
crude cartoon of what it means to me
whatever that means it means something
to me excuse me
so now the final step is how do I
actually compute this thing in practice
okay I think I don't need any of this
anymore so how do I actually compute
this in practice because doing a bunch
of summation seems kind of tedious so
I'll write down the answer and then we
can kind of convince ourselves that this
is true okay so first of all I'm going
to let Omega N equals e to the minus 2
pi I over N okay remember each of the
two pi is a
full revolution on the complex circle
just gonna draw this out one more time
so each of the two pi I means I've gone
all the way around the circle and I'm
here and if I divide it by n then what
this means is that I've moved only one
end of the way around the circle so if n
is 10 then this is one-tenth of a full
revolution if n is nine million then
this is 1/9 millionth of a full
revolution okay that's what this number
means kind of geometrically okay what we
want is all of our frequency contents F
naught hat F 1 hat F 2 hats dot dot dot
dot all the way down to F big n minus 1
hats we want this I'm gonna say this is
the Fourier coefficients Fourier
coefficients and this is our output this
is what we want from our numerical
method and this is going to equal some
big matrix hopefully times my data F 0 F
1 F 2 dot dot 2 f n minus 1 ok so this
is my data in
okay so if I can find some big matrix
that takes me from my data points to my
frequency weights that would be great
because matrix multiplication by a
vector is pretty cheap okay pretty easy
to do so that's exactly what we're going
to do if we just go back to this
expression on the Left board we know
that each each of these F K's is a sum
over all of the data times a particular
frequency so this would be kind of a row
in the matrix equation on the right and
so that that's that's one thing and
notice that if I have if I have Omega N
squared that equals e to the minus 2 pi
I times 2 over N and Omega n to the
third power is times 3 over N and so on
and so forth so I can add up you know if
I want the caithe row if I want the K
the case Fourier coefficient then I'm
going to add up my data times various
higher powers of this fundamental
frequency and it looks like this so you
can kind of check this is not too
difficult to check that what I'm going
to write down is exactly equal to the
DFT summation so I get 1 1 1 dot dot dot
1 1 Omega n Omega N squared dot dot
Omega n to the N minus 1 1 Omega N
squared Omega n to the 4th dot dot dot
Omega and to the 2 n minus 1
top that time this is a really big
matrix and then we get one Omega n to
the N minus one Omega n to the 2 times n
minus one Omega and to the power n minus
1 squared ok now this is actually a
really easy matrix to compute because I
know Omega n so it's easy to compute
Omega n to the fourth or to the ninth or
whatever I want I can compute that ok
this is a big matrix F capital F and
this is what's called the discrete
Fourier transform matrix
I literally multiply my data by a matrix
and it tells me how much of that signal
is given by each frequency sine wave you
know Omega 2 Omega 3 Omega and so on
okay
incidentally this is called a
vandermonde matrix you may have heard of
vandermonde matrix ease in the section
on curve fitting you may you may not ok
but this is the discrete Fourier
transform pretty simple to show that
this is equivalent to our summation on
the left board here and there's an
equivalent matrix that takes me from my
frequencies back to my data it's called
the inverse Fourier transform matrix and
it's not a lot more complicated ok
so that's nice and again
these F coefficients tell me how much of
my signal is given by each of these
different frequency bands
okay good so how expensive is it to take
data and to compute the Fourier
coefficients alright we've boiled it
down so that it's just matrix
multiplication by ax our big matrix so
how expensive is it how does the scale
with larger and larger signals okay how
expensive any ideas well on the on the
right board we see that you go from data
to Fourier coefficients we multiply an N
by n matrix and how expensive is it to
multiply an N by n matrix by a vector
well it's order N squared ok so this is
an order N squared operation
okay I'm going to tell you about an
algorithm tomorrow or in the next
lecture called the fast Fourier
transform now this is probably the most
important algorithm of the last 50 or
100 years the fast Fourier transform
brings the operation down to order n
times log of n which is much faster I'll
tell you a lot more about the fast
Fourier transform next lecture but
whenever someone says I'm computing the
discrete Fourier transform what they
really mean almost always is that
they're doing the fast Fourier transform
so they give you the exact same answer
but this one does it much more quickly
okay so FFT and DFT have become
completely synonymous because this is
such an important algorithm ok great so
now what I want to do is go to MATLAB
for a moment
and I want to think about a very simple
kind of toy problem where we can play
around with the FFT a little bit ok
so here what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to clear all of my memory and I'm going
to create a simple signal with two
frequencies right this is called the sum
of sines example because I'm going to
add two sine waves
I'm going to make a really small DT
point 0:01
T equals o2 DT to one and then I'm going
to say that my data vector X is equal to
sine of 2 pi times 50 times T plus sine
of 2 pi times 120 times T so I have
Omega 1 equals 50 Hertz and Omega 2
equals 120 Hertz so in my examples on
the board I said that
we were talking about some function f
over a spatial variable X here I'm
talking about a variable x over some
time T you can take a Fourier transform
of any data no matter what it means in
this case I'm talking about an audio
signal for example some you know X is
the amplitude at some time T or the
voltage coming out of a microphone so
the first thing I'm going to do is I'm
just going to plot this I'm just gonna
plot this signal save this as test FFT 1
ok and this is what my data looks like
it's kind of noisy it's not so bad I
think it's actually my MATLAB rendering
right this is what my data looks like
it looks pretty clearly like there's the
sum of two sine waves maybe okay
that's my data but excuse me and now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
compute the frequency breakdown in the
signal so I'm going to say okay n is
equal to the length of T that should be
and as a thousand in one
okay I'm going to take the FFT of my
signal X with respect sorry I'm taking
the FFT of my signal X and I'm telling
the FFT command that there's n samples
remember FFT is a fast discreet Fourier
transform
okay and what it's going to give me out
are a bunch of complex numbers remember
this is all eetu the eye 2pi whatever
and so this is going to spit out complex
numbers but what I'm really interested
in is the magnitude of the
flex numbers for each frequency this is
called the power spectral density and it
tells me how much power is in each
frequency in my original data so I say
my power spectral density is equal to Y
times the conjugate transpose of Y
divided by n so I have to scale it by my
number of samples this is my power
spectral power spectrum which tells me
how much power is in each frequency and
I'm taking Y times y transpose because
that gives me a pretty I mean that gives
me exactly the square of the length of Y
ok so this is the square of the
magnitude of that complex number and
then I have to kind of tell what my
frequencies mean I have to create a
vector of frequencies freq equals one
divided by DT times n times zero - my
number of samples this creates the X
this creates the x axis of freaks in
Hertz l equals 1 to floor and over 2 I'm
only going to plot the first half of
freaks and then I'm going to plot my
frequencies versus my power spectral
density okay this is I'm just labeling
it power spectrum X label is frequency
in Hertz and what should I call the Y
label the Y label is just the power so
bigger Y more power ok so on the left
this is our original data signal and on
the right we see this is the power
spectrum so this tells me how much power
exists in each of these frequencies
and notice right off the bat we can see
pretty nicely a very good peak at 50
Hertz and 120 Hertz that's where all of
the power in the signal exists is that
50 Hertz and 120 Hertz which is really
good because that's actually the signal
that I constructed right it's the sum of
two sine waves one of 50 Hertz and one
of 120 Hertz okay so we're going to
think a lot more about this over the
next couple of lectures we're going to
use this for some great examples in
image compression and audio compression
and filtering and we're gonna keep
building up an intuition for what this
discrete Fourier transform really is and
what it's useful for but probably the
most interesting thing for us to do is
just really get comfortable with using
it okay let's take an engineering
perspective on the discrete Fourier
transform and just kind of explore all
of the cool things you can do with it
okay that's all for now I'll see you in
the next lecture